avec vous ce matin hélène frade bonjour
hélène avec vous que dix comme tous les
matins bonjour l ennemi à la une de la
presse internationale donc les
accusations des états unis pour
commencer hélène qui accusent la chine
donc d'être disposés à soutenir
militairement la russie dans la guerre
en ukraine d'après le financial times
washington a prévenu ses alliés que
pékin aurait accueilli favorablement la
demande de moscou de lui fournir des
équipements militaires notamment des
missiles air-sol des véhicules blindés
et des drones notamment peu de temps
après les jo de pékin vladimir poutine
et jean ping ont annoncé un partenariat
sans limites la question est désormais
de vérifier s'il n'y a vraiment pas de
limite à ce partenariat écrit le
quotidien britannique en prévenant que
si pékin accepte la demande de moscou
alors la chine entrera de fait dans une
guerre par procuration avec les états
unis et le temps en france libération
dit accueillir avec prudence ces
allégations américaines mais estime que
si ces accusations sont avérées alors
elle confirme les difficultés auxquelles
moscou semble faire face en ukraine etc
elles obligeront aussi pékin a abandonné
sa pseudo neutralité à mettre fin à son
trouble jeu la chine gêné aux
entournures sas à la guerre en ukraine
c'est d'avoir aussi avec ce dessin de
brian adcock pour des in deep and then
qui montre on le voit le panda chinois
obligé de se contorsionner pour éviter
les pattes ensanglanté de vladimir
poutine quelle réaction en chine
degroote times fait état de la rencontre
hier à rome entre le conseiller à la
sécurité nationale de joe biden est le
plus haut responsable du pcc pour la
diplomatie une réunion présentée comme
une tentative des états unis de faire
pression sur la chine pour qu'elle
applique les sanctions contre la russie
mais pékin ne s'y trompent pas et
dénonce l'arrogance de washington qui
vont obliger d'autres pays à suivre un
conditionnement sa stratégie simple le
journal china daily
consacre lui sa une à l'aide humanitaire
pauline envoyé par la chine à l'ukraine
la troisième cargaison de ce type selon
le quotidien officiel qui évoque une
livraison de provisions d'alimentation
pour bébé et de couverture notamment les
ong disclose accuse quant à elle la
france d'avoir équipé l'armée russe cse
entre 2015 et 2020 malgré l' escalade
militaire déjà avec l'ukraine selon le
site d'investigation français l'armement
de la france aurait permis à vladimir
poutine de moderniser sa flotte de tanks
d'avions de chasse et d'hélicoptères de
combat des équipements susceptibles
d'être utilisés actuellement en ukraine
selon disclose les gouvernements de
françois hollande puis d'emmanuel macron
aurait profité d'une brèche dans la
législation européenne du fait que
l'embargo sur les armes à destination de
la russie qui a été décidé en 2014 et
bien n'est pas rétroactif la russie est
là nous il est toujours interdit
d'employer le mot guerre pardon pour
évoquer le conflit en ukraine malgré
elle est très lourde peine encourue une
jeune femme marina official nico va a
pris le risque hier d'interrompre un
journal à la télé russe en plein direct
en brandissant une pancarte arrêter la
guerre ne croyait pas la propagande ils
vous mentent une initiative courageuse
qui était la une ce matin de plusieurs
quotidiens à travers le monde et
notamment du guardian qui précise que la
jeune femme a été arrêtée cette photo
est publiée également sur le site du
journal russe novaïa gazeta et on le
voir le journal a été obligé de flouter
une partie de cette pancarte pour ne pas
se retrouver donc en infraction avec la
loi au royaume uni hélène boris johnson
ne confirme pas pas pour le moment en
tout cas les proches les rumeurs d'une
prochaine visite en arabie saoudite pour
une demande et éventuellement une
augmentation de la production de pétrole
pour remplacer les approvisionnements de
russie l'éventualité d'une telle visite
provoque des remous outre manche the
guardian rapporte que certains députés
britanniques s'indigne notamment de ce
qu'un tel déplacement intervient
seulement quelques jours après
l'exécution annoncé samedi
de 80 à condamner à mort le guardian
prévient que l'opposition à vladimir
poutine ne doit pas conduire le royaume
uni à apaiser des dictateurs tout aussi
répugnants je cite brent johnson veut se
précipiter de manière humiliante pour
implorer mohammed bin salman de baisser
le prix du pétrole que proposera t-il en
échange de fermer les yeux sur le
meurtre d'état du journaliste jamal
rachid j sur la dévastation continue des
yéménites ou l'exécution de 81 hommes
dont certains étaient des prisonniers
politiques dans le dessin de mode
moerlen pour des times le premier
ministre britannique nage dans le sens
des prisonniers saoudiens et déclare au
prince héritier mohammed bin salman 10
mb/s il sauve des vies on ne se quittent
pas là dessus et la mère ne se quittent
pas rapidement avant de vous dira tout à
l'heure rapidement je vous propose de
jeter un silo times qui s'amuse des
photos qui ont été prises dimanche à
l'elysée par la photographe officiel d'
emmanuel macron ces clichés montrent on
le voit emmanuel macron pas rasés en
tenue décontractée jeans bleus et sweat
noir siglé cap 17 unités parachutistes
d'élite une tenue que le journel
évidemment comparé aux tee shirt kaki et
autres tenues militaires du président
ukrainien
volodimir zelensky merci beaucoup et
l'aisne à tout à l'heure dans paris
direct